our greatest threat for thousands of
years
no not Mark Carney's predictions of
economic collapse if we crash out of the
EU czars deal this is the UN General
Assembly president Maria Espinosa who
also said mankind is in danger of
disappearing if we don't act together to
halt climate change puts it in
perspective doesn't it miss Espinosa was
speaking at a summit in Poland involving
nearly 200 nations which aims to build
on the landmark 2015 Paris climate
Accord that sets a goal of limiting
global warming to 1.5 percent above
pre-industrial levels the climate change
skeptic in the White House meanwhile has
pulled the u.s. out of the Paris Accords
he shouldn't be allowed to get away with
it sanctions tariffs we need to do
whatever it takes to get the u.s. to
decarbonize and engage with the greatest
challenge the world has ever faced
so forget brexit for a moment today's
generation is the last that can prevent
catastrophic global warming as well as
the first to be suffering its impacts
climate change must be the priority of
all governments including the u.s. as
they say there is no planet B
[Music]
well as one of the older members of the
pledge this afternoon as opposed to
course Greg who is the oldest I have
been around long enough I have been
round long enough to remember so many
scare stories if I didn't stop using my
underarm deodorant we could burn a hole
in the ozone layer and we don't we'd all
be roaches the millennium bug the
millennium bug planes were please let me
finish
millennium bug will have planes fall out
of the sky bank accounts with the
reality is people love to scare
themselves is is there an issue yes
there is an issue it is not of the
magnitude that you described and
interesting enough you psyche President
Trump and we might hear from him in a
moment presumably your darling of the
liberal elite Emmanuel macron look
what's happened to him in France when he
tried to take the appropriate measures
yes there are riots all over Paris
they've now finished because of the tax
on fuel and especially diesel which is
the workers so in summary in summary is
it a problem undoubtedly a problem does
it need to be addressed of course it
needs to be addressed is it of this
magnitude no people up people humankind
is incredibly small experts experts back
to you I know you have been around the
block a very long time and you we have
had a lot of hot air from you honest
enough frankly to heat the bloody planet
to about three look panel some of us
must have some experts so I have a
statement here from the chairman of the
least developed countries group
juh brugge ember and what debris says is
the LDC group represents almost 1
billion people these are the people who
are the least responsible for climate
change but among those most vulnerable
to its effects trillions of dollars in
crime
finance is needed to cover the costs of
adapting to climate change impacts
coping with loss and damage and pursuing
Clean Development pathways to avoid
emissions Nick how can you say what you
just said I'd agreed we see what's
happening to our planet every day even
in places where they have more than
enough resources they're still not able
to tackle this problem but as strange
for myself to be agreeing with Nick but
I mean clearly there's a massive problem
and I think the risk is too great to
take but politically I don't know how
you do it you do look at what's
happening pastor look in America when I
elected from one of the factors they
elected tranform was because you didn't
believe in climate change there's a
whole chunk of America who the economics
of that region basically depend on not
believing in climate change
the trouble is how you achieve this is a
politician in a democracy in democratic
reform while leaders sure but if you
really last about three days and then
the feds I mean can we just hear from
the UN has appointed a people spokesman
on climate change and it's our own David
Attenborough who said even older than
you can we just hear what he has to say
because it's so easy just to think this
is so big and it's so frightening this
has got nothing to do with me and I
can't do anything but we've all got to
do something and he knows all of us
right now we're facing a man-made
disaster of global scale our greatest
threat in thousands of years climate
change if we don't take action the
collapse of our civilizations and the
extinction of much of the natural world
is on the horizon everybody thinks it's
just so enormous it's gonna happen I
can't do anything but we can do
something 12 years there is a you know
you can go online and you can look at
the UN's new act now chatbot Nick I'm
sure you'll be doing a cynical
stop me can we just see we've got just
sorry Caroline if we are going to save
the world this is what we need to do
greenhouse gas emissions need to be cut
by forty five percent by 2030 to limit
this global temperature rise to 1.5
percent I mean if it goes up to two
percent we lose over the coral yeah we
lose coastal cities yeah I mean this is
serial track 4 - sorry Carol I'm trying
to work out when I realized this was
your subject why why people don't do
anything about it and I and I think it's
because it's hard for our brains to take
in threats about the future and being
asked to make sacrifices now about
something that's going to happen in the
future and also I think we all don't
think if we can't individually do
anything big enough to solve what we all
think it's someone else's problem you
think it's a scientist problem and if
and we don't directly suffer from
climate change effect if you like
enjoying the way California yet but and
I think it's just it's hard for people
to get the head round and it's hard for
them to take any action well I think in
the end people and as you saw and make
it they vote for what is a short term
yeah and their own economics in their
own lives and as you say it needs very
brave politicians yeah McCombs my brave
politicians well not when it turned ugly
I said what do we do yeah yeah and they
didn't know it and that's the problem
with it is actually politically I don't
know how you solve it I do think that I
think that human beings naturally do
take the long-term approach when you
look at yeah yeah if you look at the way
people sacrifice for their children to
have a better life so I think if we were
able to position it in that way you know
I just think what am I able to do tell
me what I meant to do there's lots of
things that might want you well I
recycle got an energy-efficient car what
else could I do nobody first thing you
can do exactly cycling if I may say so
the first thing you can do is even
simple things like making sure that all
of your electronics are switched off
when you're not using them you're not
just leaving the plug running there's
stuff that we all do
get the butler to do that yeah actually
instead of going to supermarkets that
have lots of plastic packaging and so on
go back to the markets it's a bit better
but it seems our money's in China yeah
which I'm done and you see factory after
factory after thank you yeah I'm gonna
bring out this stuff into the atmosphere
you think yeah mine recycle is not you
just met as well this is from Molly
Scott from the Green Party Molly Scott
Cato speaking at the extinction
rebellion protests I have to say they
caused so much hassle last week but hey
this is what she had to say this is all
about the fact that we're not seeing the
action we need to see about climate
change we've got 12 years left to make
sure that my survivors as a human
civilization on this planet
internationally the countries of the
world have recognized that we're just
not seeing the climate emergency action
that we need to see so people have come
here today right next to see their
houses of parliament to say we need much
more urgent action from our politicians
I think we need serious policy change I
think we need to be hard on people
you'll get used to it in the isn't until
there's a political will to do it I'm
not entirely sure how that's going to
happen and I don't see it